el conflicto de Sudán podría convertirse
en una guerra civil así lo ha advertido
la ONU a pocos días de cumplirse tres
meses desde que iniciaron los
enfrentamientos entre el ejército y el
grupo paramilitar fuerzas de apoyo
rápido en su disputa por obtener El
poder del país africano
Aparentemente ninguna de las partes
puede ganar militarmente con lo que
tienen en términos de mano de obra por
lo tanto han reclutado Más allá de sus
propias formaciones sobre una base
étnica y tribal estamos al borde de que
la guerra se convierta en una guerra
civil étnica y tribalizada
a pesar de los enfrentamientos diarios
el jefe de la misión de las Naciones
Unidas en Sudán ha dicho que ninguna de
las partes Ha logrado avances
significativos dentro de la capital
hartum el objetivo principal planteado
desde el 15 de abril
viviendas y otras propiedades civiles
han sido ocupadas así como los saqueos
generalizados se han convertido en la
normalidad en Sudán generando carencia
crítica de alimentos limitaciones en el
acceso a servicios de salud y de
primeros auxilios lo que ha obligado al
menos a 2.2 millones de personas a
movilizarse a otras zonas del país y a
otros 700.000 la huir a países vecinos
se han observado movimientos mixtos a
través de la frontera hacia Egipto chat
Sudán del sur Etiopía y la República
centroafricana de las más de 697.000
personas que cruzaron a los países
vecinos el 65% son sudaneses y se estima
que el 35% son repatriados y nacionales
de terceros países la mayoría se
encuentran en condiciones extremadamente
precarias cifra reveladas en víspera de
que los países del Golfo celebren una
cumbre en Egipto con el fin de abordar
las formas para finalizar la violencia y
lidiar con las consecuencias de la
prolongación del conflicto